moving on to Delta Airlines it's one of
the world's largest airlines and delta
expects to fly a record 5.2 million
passengers worldwide around Thanksgiving
that's a up about two and a half percent
from last year the Atlanta based carrier
flies more than 15,000 flights every day
it takes nearly 200 million travelers to
their destinations every year Delta
Airlines CEO is Eadie Bastian he just
joins us at the table to discuss
navigating holiday travel and the big
issues facing the airline industry good
to see you back Bastian thanks Gail
great you weren't really worried about
jetpacks putting you out of business
I was just watching that I I'm out I'm
not doing that got a more comfortable
experience I'm gonna stick with Delta
Toni by the ways to Tulsa time I've
already told them I already did well you
did so let's talk about the 7:30 max
planes there are none of those than the
Delta fleet at this time no we do not
have that plane we did not order it not
planning to did you not order it because
you were concerned or you just didn't
order it
no we did an order for all the reasons
obviously safety wasn't part of that
consideration so today I tell people
sometimes you'd rather be lucky than
smart and that was probably more more
fortunate but the reality is it's it's
it was not a technology we want to
advance the Delta does have a lot of
business with Boeing do you think Boeing
is doing enough to ensure our safety
absolutely Boeing is a amazing company
and we were the second largest operator
Boeing equipment in the world we fly
over six on your Boeing Boeing aircraft
there's no question that this is going
to bring up opportunities to improve
safety and Lauren more as we go forth
but the transportation in the u.s.
particularly air travel is the safest of
any transportation system in the world
everybody always says that edie but when
you're up in the air and the flight
starts doing that differently doodle
stuff it does not feel state but
everybody says and the statistics bear
it out I know I statistics bear it out
there's not a safer form of travel
including walking across the street yeah
would be if they if would you consider
flying the revamp 737 max I would I
would yeah obviously it needs to
continue to go through the certification
process the faa you know makes that
decision and once the regulators get
comfortable with it I have no doubt it's
going to be a little thing
that's a total total fight let's talk
about prices for a second Delta is
investing 12 billion I think it is yeah
Airport renovation yeah talk me through
why that is the right investment as
opposed to you know shaving 12 billion
off ticket prices for people flying to
see family over Thanksgiving I don't
vote for that yeah you go for that too
well one of the things that we know we
hear from our customers all the time
it's the real stress of travel is the
ground experience and right here in New
York LaGuardia LaGuardia is probably
ground zero for for an airport it really
needs to be rebuilt and we're doing that
so of that 12 billion almost four
billion dollars we're spending in
building the new LaGuardia Airport we've
got new airports going up in LA Seattle
Salt Lake City we're modernizing Atlanta
we're modernizing Minneapolis and the
flight experience has substantially
improved over over time the real stress
for me is squeezing into those small
seats well the seats that Delta haven't
changed the seats in years when we
haven't changed this new in years so I
think there's a lot of different types
of airlines there's a lot of look
there's a lot of low-cost airlines that
will that will sell at the lowest cost
possible we offer different different
products and different products for
different fare levels but the other
thing is told you earlier is that real
fares even an inflation-adjusted basis
are down 40% including fees over the
last 25 years
so the skies have become become
democratized and that's why we're seeing
the volumes and the growth and we'll
continue to see the growth that's why
we've got to build bigger airports using
technology to help people and that's why
you're saying more people are flying
because the fares have in fact gone down
absolutely although when you go the
ticket counter doesn't feel like that
but I think it's good to say that yeah
that's important it's important to know
that absolutely it's a great it's a
great bargain if you go back you know
since the 1980s when deregulation hit
our industry it's been a revolution in
terms of change within and the big thing
is that more people can travel is coming
as such a part of society speaking of
travel what are you expecting for a
Holloway holiday travel and what are
your tips for getting through it
well our demands gonna be great we're
looking at the books for the next week
for the Thanksgiving week we're looking
at about five million customers travel
about how it's done your airline it's
just on our airline largest largest that
we've seen in our history how can it go
more smoothly for people well our people
are ready and we're prepared and we got
to have one of the tips that I always
tell people a couple things one is
make sure you're signed up to go through
the clear process to clear it is a
game-changer India of going through
security will get you through security
in minutes compared to any other the
other thing is the fly Delta app the fly
delta app is like having your own
concierge in your pocket and we've added
technology such that even if you get
stuck in an airport with your on the app
there's a live chat feature that's your
best way to get in touch airline that's
the best way to get in touch real-time
is using the fly tilt table and your
number in case people want to get I feel
soon they'll see me a coach on the plane
most the time yeah why well it's where
the real people are I find it a lot more
interesting back there yeah but the real
reason there's some real people but the
real first-class were paid for those
suits and they don't that is true all
right thank you yeah the real people
they said are in the control